and I fear that one consequence of the
Iraqi difficult is that we are much less
likely to intervene on the one hand
there's just a shortage of troops you
know everybody's preoccupied in Iraq or
to some extent Afghanistan on the other
hand there is a no more stomach for
military action I think people have just
had it with with these adventures
overseas want the troops home and are
not about to launch into another one and
end in a third perspect the Bush
administration is discredited the
concept of humanitarian intervention by
trying to justify the Iraqi war after
the fact as a humanitarian intervention
when we all know that at the time it was
supposedly defined the non-existent
weapons of mass destruction or was to
attack the non-existent links with
international terrorism but if if we
knew that there were no weapons of mass
destruction if it was clearly there was
no al Qaeda connection Bush would not
have gone in just because Saddam was a
tyrant but after the fact by trying to
justify the Iraq war as a humanitarian
intervention one that I don't think is
justified because bad as the tyrant is
Saddam was there was not the mass
slaughter of the time that would have
justified humanitarian intervention Bush
has given the term given the concept of
bad name um he's really tarde what is I
think a very you know a high-minded
concept with his fairly base political
needs and in the process I think it's
people say like the people of Darfur who
are paying the price because you know
why is the international community only
willing to go into Darfur with the
consent of the Sudanese government you
know consent that has been withheld for
a very long time it's because there is
no more you know stomach there's no more
capacity to use military force but also
because people are now skeptical of this
console
humanitarian intervention and so in that
sense the people of Darfur or of eastern
Congo or others facing mass atrocities
are very much paying the price of this
this cheap resort to or in an effort to
justify it after the fact as a
humanitarian